[Music]
hello welcome my name is Jonathan
Pulsifer I'm a security engineer at
Shopify and today I'm here with a couple
other folks and whom I'll introduce
momentarily but we're gonna talk to you
about a keyless entry that is securely
accessing Google cloud platform services
from within kubernetes before we get
started though I'd like to just mention
that we have a Dory here I've not used
this before
good luck if you would like to ask us
some questions this is how we can do
this but also we're gonna have a
pedestal like to take any questions from
the audience when we're done
so again hi my name is John I'm a staff
infrastructure security engineer at
Shopify I like to hang around with Mike
and other folks on the kubernetes
product security committee and I'm a
Google developer expert for the cloud
platform with the focus on security
before coming to Shopify I get my
tinfoil hat and the Royal Canadian Navy
where I'm a self-described singing cyber
sailor so that's where that came from
and previous to that did a little bit of
instructing for the SANS Institute in
cyber security you can find me on the
Internet John Pulsifer with me here
today we have Aaron small who's a p.m.
that is project a product manager for
Google GK and kubernetes security he
works on identity things and has
recently pushed out the third party
audit for our security wait for
kubernetes which is really really neat
so look him up and look that up I think
it's fantastic
previously I used to be a p.m. for other
places and I wish I could bake as well
as Aaron can my bread doesn't turn out
as nice as his these days Aaron cares a
lot about the blast radius of things and
trusts yeah generally Mike Denis who you
may know from the kubernetes community
is a software engineer at Google and
works on GK security
he's a chair of the kubernetes special
interest group for off that'sa goth and
is the tech lead on gk identity stuff
and like Seattle a lot
so before we dive into the the meat I
have a little bit of a story to tell you
before we get into the story I'd like to
thank the folks at bright carbon for
turning our diagram into what it was
before into what it is now and that's
very pretty
and we use this to talk about Java fine
so Shopify for those who don't know is a
multi-channel commerce platform that
Google cloud platform now has over 50
gke clusters in production the power
over 800,000 businesses and 175
different countries and we allow people
to sell things to people the people who
sell things are everyone from me my
grandmother and then big brands such as
Kylie cosmetics Albert's
and a lot more so meet Emily Emily is a
Deb degree internet shopify the Deb
degree program is like a work integrated
learning program that takes university
students first year university students
and puts them on the fast track to being
developers that are that are really
impactful and we do this by like
layering on personal development skills
and technology stacks like the ones we
use at Shopify primarily Ruby on Rails
feedback loops and and other things too
to really help them grow and become
developers it's like a really intense
co-op program right and she's doing all
this stuff on top of a degree right for
someone who doesn't have a degree I
think this is really next-level stuff
and I just don't quite understand it I
don't think that I could work as hard as
she does but in any event emily is
studying her first year at computer
science at Carleton University in Ottawa
and we helped her build cool things so
in just a few clicks
emily is empowered to create new things
she explore her ideas
she doesn't have to reason about
debugging our production stack like it
just it just works right and with a
little familiarity maybe like a breeze
through the documentation I mean who
reads those Emily and other developers
other developers like her
Shopify can really deploy like a fresh
Ruby on
eles application that's completely
configured everything from cloud sequel
Redis memcache D protected by our
implementation of an identity aware
proxy that's Minerva and the cloud
bosses and any other friendly kubernetes
controllers that keep our cloud fluffy
the pieces of the cloud that I want to
highlight today are the ones that reason
about identity and one that we haven't
really talked about before the pieces
that bootstrap our cloud runtimes is
ground control and ground control was
missing from our previous diagrams
because it was just like one of those
things that you know you thought would
go away right hey we built it and it was
like pretty resourceful it was quite
scrappy but then it turned out to be
like a critical part of the production
stack and so I figured I'd talk about
ground control as it relates to the
larger identity problem at Shopify so
the parts of ground control that are
really important are the initialization
of the kubernetes namespace the
generation of the asymmetric key pair
for encrypted Jason that's where
developers store secrets you can find
that at github Shopify II Jason and the
last piece the part that relates to
today is the creation of the Google
cloud platform service account identity
so this is like the genesis of identity
for a service at Shopify really happens
at ground control so some other
controllers that help keep the cloud
fluffy at Shopify these are the cloud
buddies we really like to talk about the
cloud buddies because it it it takes
away all of this technical complexity
and makes it and makes it more friendly
and so these are my favorite ones thanks
to David Neil for for bringing the cloud
buddies to life Napo buddy ensures that
our kubernetes network policy objects
are in place our back buddy does the
same thing for kubernetes our back
bucket buddy really helps us lifecycle
our GCS buckets and accountabilibuddy my
favorite grants IM bindings for GCP
api's and binds the service accounts to
be able to access these things
so Google service accounts are are
something else right to use an East
Coast expression there right out of her
I'm from the east coast of Canada I
don't really like to use twelve dollar
words to express myself so you'll you'll
find I use a lot of colorful concise and
expressive language to do that and so
the few things that I wanted to
highlight about Google service accounts
and that is to demystify them is that
when there are two types you have the
Google managed service accounts and you
have user managed service accounts the
Google managed service accounts are the
ones that you'll find in your IM page
that looked like your project number
which a lot of people don't know at a
Google product project I am Dodie
service account calm you can't generate
credentials off these these are the
robots that keep Google's cloud fluffy
you know and and empower the ship as a
word the user managed service accounts
the the user managed GSA is are the part
that's hard and and I want to talk about
why they're hard and and and hopefully
you will come out understanding that
they are difficult to manage as well so
the second part of that is that the keys
are not well understood right we have
this documentation in the cloud platform
that says like hey look security bits
let's just create this JSON blob and jam
it in this Google application
credentials environment variable quick
hands up who can explain to me so our
audience participation is definitely
gonna happen today by me and Aaron and
the whole works so hands up if you can
explain to me all the technical bits
that power Google applicant application
credentials this is like so we got like
the security PM so who have one like and
that's it right that says all that it
needs to save is it not you know it's
just a fun security bit that you throw
over the wall to the security team and
say yeah have fun right the last piece
that I wanted to highlight is that it
works thanks shop a fam is left in for
sec right and we provide a lot of
support to our developers we have over a
thousand developers at Shopify and they
don't know how service accounts work
either and so we have to help them
figure out this maze of credentials and
identity and access management and what
it all means right thirdly the keys are
unreasonably hard to manage and and I
say that because buried in the
documentation says in another language
that you should really really really not
use Google or user managed service
accounts unless you have the following
in place and again hands up if everyone
like knows how to fully manage a PKI
like very well write like we have a few
again but like we've all created a CA
right like we've all created the self
sign CA but what about like managing CR
ELLs at scale or OCSP you know how does
that all work and where does this all
fit in these are like core competencies
of a PKI that's actually required if you
are to effectively manage like thousands
of these keys right and so that's that's
the really hard bit it's it's not easy
and that's what I want you to come away
with today so user managed GSA
credentials live forever right ten years
is forever in cloud years by the way and
there are actually technologies that
we're familiar with already they're
typically in the JSON blobs a2k RSA key
pair generated off the PKI that is your
project and the common name is its
unique ID so if you think you can just
like delete things and use the certs
again and come back it just it just
doesn't work there's a lot of nuance in
that a lot of PKI nuance and it's it's
not easy
Shopify found out that we push the
limits of a lot of the the products in
the Google cloud platform because we
poked at the bits that that people don't
expect us to you the PM's don't really
expect us to and we found out the hard
way that when you reach 1,000 user
manage GSA's per project that I am
doesn't let you list them anymore
and so given that it's like a slight
denial of service against I am we got
the feedback that we should probably do
something else and so now we have
multiple projects which only hold GSA's
service account credentials
like that's wild right and how do you
like reason about these things are we
confident that these credentials aren't
misused an employee that that left had a
hot exit you know are we confident that
any keys didn't go along with them we
generally do a good job at auditing
these things but there are just a lot of
keys that that have grown with us
through the years and that I would deem
as as sensitive and and we'd like to do
something better right we'd like we like
to change and so given all of this this
doesn't include identities for like the
instances or the nodes or the gk node
Poole says this is just like service
accounts that have been created for
applications that run on our cloud
platform this is not the rest of them
these like 1200 so service accounts that
I mentioned are just for services so we
in fact have a lot more so all that to
say is that containers that run at
Shopify in our cloud platform are
experiencing what I would call as a
conflict of identity and you know we've
created these cloud buddies and their
other kubernetes controllers and some
other automation we're a software
company we recreate cool things to help
solve our problems for us but it scaling
does come with us challenges right like
over a thousand servers accounts per
project thing so the the product that
you wrote to see the technology that
you're about to see really hopes to
address a lot of these problems and
further like consolidate the the
identities of workloads bridging trust
domains as it were
I mean kubernetes we would just call
this a namespace right if we could just
namespace a series of identities
wouldn't that be neat but Who am I to
say so with that I like definitions I
like these these twelve dollar words and
expressions so Erin will give you a lot
more of these there are a few more
definitions I stole one from him and
it's this one because I think it's it's
really important so we do a lot of
talking about workloads today workloads
workloads are everything everywhere and
what I mean by that is that it's their
software running on a computer they are
containers there were their binaries
they're just they're just a thing
talking to a modern authentication
system right and so workloads that
Shopify including human workloads
leverage short-lived signed gwt's jots
as it were for tools like G cloud cube
cuddle all these tools use these
technologies and so the impact here
really is that you know we interact with
these technologies as humans more than
we probably realize that we do it powers
accounts table fight comm you know that
is our identity application at Shopify
every oauth2 proxy that you've ever used
the Biblio auth to proxy buzzfeed SSO
and the whole thing and and Google right
so it's it's largely my opinion that we
should be consolidating these these
identities identities we should be
consolidating all these technologies and
and using them as just as everybody else
is so with that I'm gonna hand it over
to Aaron and he's gonna show you
something new thank you see if I can
figure this out so as I was getting
ready for this talk and putting these
slides together a lot of the feedback I
got from my peers was that I tried to
cover too many complicated topics in the
time that I had and I didn't go into
enough depth on any given one of them to
actually explain it in full and they
were right but I think that actually
points to a bigger story and that bigger
story is that identity and credential
management is hard like capital age hard
it's a really deep space you have to
worry about credential issuance and
distribution and that long list that
Jonathan listed off earlier and
revocation and auditing and renewal and
exfiltration protection that's my first
$12 word and replay protection and on
and on and on if you add to that the
alphabet soup of all the standards you
have to deal with like Oh IDC jots RFC
75 18 and then you layer on top of that
all the unique authentication and
authorization
systems that each cloud provider
implements I could end up talking for
like two hours when all Emily asked was
how do I access cloud storage from gke
so did the work to simplify the
presentation we won't cover the my
favorite RFC use and their finer
implementation details but more
importantly than that I think we
simplified the practice Jonathan from
Eastern Canada addressed these problems
with some really heroic engineering and
actually shouldered some of Emily's
burden and he definitely made Emily's
life easier I want to take a step back
and look at how this works for the rest
of the world don't accept I'm from a big
old West Coast city by the bay and I'm
gonna use as many $12 words as I can so
if the first thing you do is you you go
to I am and you create an IM service
account then you download its key and
when you download that key you get this
lovely little warning and it's perfectly
accurate like don't get me wrong you
should read it carefully because it's
perfectly true and then you have all
these keys and this is actually a
screenshot from one of my own personal
accounts and I have a very good reason I
assure you for having this many keys
downloaded but I'm not going to tell you
what it is once you have this key you
run to some cube cuddle commands against
it and you end up with a kubernetes
secret and then you can update though
your kubernetes yamo files with this
secret and you have to mount it in
places that the Google client library is
know to look and that's pretty much it
once you mount this secret in all the
right places
your kubernetes workloads know which
identity to use when talking to google
cloud and at first glance there's
nothing really wrong with this approach
right like from a strict threat modeling
perspective as long as there's no
vulnerabilities anywhere in your
application or anywhere in kubernetes or
in any of your dependencies it's
probably fine kubernetes handles secrets
in really rational ways it's not gonna
accidentally expose it to the wrong
workload however manageability gets
quite complex if you have thousands of
these keys that you're managing is
individual secrets and various
kubernetes cluster is you have to build
a system to manage them and then
furthermore if it if it does get
compromised if someone does manage to
get their hands on one of these sea
they can exfiltrate it they can take it
with them and once they have it back
home they can use it to perform whatever
malicious action they had planned until
either you notice or until it expires in
ten years
which I guess is forever in cloud land
so this all comes down to this concept
of blast radius and security
professionals like me always talk about
blast radius but what this really means
is let's first assume that something's
going to go wrong when this thing goes
wrong what else breaks and I don't mean
what pieces of your applications stopped
working I mean what fundamental security
assumptions are no longer valid when
something else goes wrong
we used to call this defense-in-depth
now we called it building to reduce
blast radius it all means roughly the
same thing which is making it as hard as
possible for an attacker turn one
vulnerability in one part of your
application into a successful attack on
another brief aside on containers I love
containers they help a lot when it comes
to reducing the blast radius you can use
some really cool security features you
can lock them down to only access
certain certain kernel what's the word
that's right you can only access certain
syscalls you can make their file systems
read-only the committee is networking
plugins and provide good policies to
access limit access then there's
products both on top of the whole thing
like sto that can provide great
encryption of all these inter container
communication and can provide a
management layer but in real life these
containers have to interact with each
other and they also have to interact
with other cloud services and once you
do that you find yourself back at square
one which was credential management is
hard when I'm building a cloud native
application I care about the credentials
and I care about blast radius but that
doesn't mean I want to manage the
individual life cycles of every secret
and every key that my identity system
relies on I do want to make these broad
security statements like this component
can only talk to that thing this cloud
service only has access to this role or
can call this one API
the implementation details of credential
lifecycle management and key lifecycle
management should be automatic and it's
managed by the cloud provider I guess
what I'm saying is the best way to solve
the credential management problem is to
get somebody else to do it for you
especially if they'll be a fool enough
to stand up on stage and volunteer to do
it there's so many edge cases to
consider there are so many best
practices to be aware of and to enforce
I would want a whole team of people that
were dedicated to its design and
maintenance oh yeah my turn for audience
participation although I can barely see
you so who has used a kubernetes service
account or an IM service account on any
cloud divider alright I want you to keep
your hands up if you've ever built your
own identity system from scratch ok so
there's a couple of you that's awesome
towards the end of the talk I'm gonna
come back up and we can nerd out on
implementation until then standby go
right so Shopify was really really great
to work with on this problem space they
have electronic and mentioned this habit
of pushing on all the bits of our
service we maybe didn't expect to get
pushed on that hard when we talked about
this set of problems their perspective
was really valuable to the eventual
design we landed on we heard from
Jonathan and many others that the
process of accessing Google cloud
services from within kubernetes engine
was really onerous that managing these
long-lived secrets and all these I am
service accounts was very painful and
then additionally as security
professionals neither myself nor
Jonathan and we're happy with all these
keys just flying around everywhere
either being unmanaged entirely or being
managed in a decentralized way so we
decided to take a crack at the solution
and this is what we came up with today
I'm introducing work load identity it'll
be in beta in a few weeks and it's
designed to help people like Jonathan
and Emily and also for all the security
folks in the room to help you sleep a
little better at night last year I gave
a big speech about trust and how using a
cloud provider is an exercise and Trust
I think part of that relationship is we
need to offer services for you to build
on top of that are built on really
strong
security principles so we're cloud
identity makes it easy to access
communities sorry Google cloud products
from within credit engine without
becoming an expert in identity without
becoming an expert in credential
management you don't have to manage any
keys or any secrets related to this we
have this new concept called an identity
namespace and I'll go into exactly what
that means more in a minute but in short
it's gonna allow you to define the
relationship between kubernetes
workloads and the Google Cloud
identities that they should use without
a bunch of excess micromanagement it's
gonna work across clusters and it works
with the existing Google client
libraries that you're probably already
using I think I think you're gonna get
someone else to solve a problem like
this for you it's only fair that you
understand the kinds of principles that
led to the design they ended up on with
I like sharing principles like this I
think it builds a lot of trust and I
think it helps you understand why we
made the trade-offs we did and maybe
even give you a little insight into the
direction that we're going so the first
major principle we designed towards was
least privilege all that really means is
not giving any one component more
permissions than it actually needs in
this instance it means we can't force
you to be less string G with your
permissions than you want to be and
specifically that means we couldn't rely
on the underlying virtual machine
service account identity because of the
way kubernetes scheduling works your
workload could get end up scheduled on
any given node and in that case you'd
have to grant too many permissions of
the underlying node secondly if a
component that's running workload
identity gets compromised we need its
blast radius to be like as small as
possible we primarily achieve this by
making sure the the long-lived durable
secrets that underpin this whole system
are never exposed to workloads at all
and the access tokens that we do expose
expire very quickly and finally I wanted
the solution to play nice with
kubernetes criminais has engine
customers are probably our customers
because they love kubernetes so we
wanted to design the solution in a way
that
seamlessly and followed the best
practices and the way the communities
likes to do things all right so if we're
gonna integrate seamlessly with
kubernetes and if we're gonna build this
identity system let's take a brief aside
and look at what we have to work with
this is like creators cluster you've
probably seen it before it's a got a
control plane it's got nodes nodes uh
pods your workload lives in those pods
got a bunch of API API objects I didn't
think we'd have a screen this big so you
probably can read them on the left we've
got a bunch that result in the creation
of pods and then on the right you've got
a bunch that provide various controls
for your cluster the one that we
actually care about in this case is the
surface camp so the kubernetes surface
account it's really good
junction point for communities
identities and Google Cloud identities
you can create them really easily just a
couple of lines of yeah Mille you can
associate them with a workload with one
line in your config file and I think
most importantly you can set them up as
the default for an entire crew brandies
namespace that can be really useful if
you have a complicated or large
infrastructure to manage except your
environment probably didn't look like
that I am assuming that most
environments look more like this we've
got multiple clusters they're talking to
each other they're talking to Google
cloud they're talking to multiple cloud
providers and we wanted the solution
that we build to look something to be
something that works for the real world
for you so enter the identity namespace
and this is my perfectly accurate and
entirely incomprehensible definition
Jonathan stole my other definition slide
so I'm keeping this one I know it's it's
usually easier to go through these
things by explaining what they do rather
than what they are but we're gonna we're
gonna use this one anyway an identity
namespace is a scope in which a name
uniquely identifies a principle and what
I mean by scope is we're gonna be using
this identity namespace to define a
collection of other things and within
that collection anything with the same
name is actually the same thing so you
can imagine it's like a magic room where
everybody named Alice is
actually the same person it's kind of a
strange concept in the abstract but it
has some really useful principles that
will we'll get into and this will but it
looks like in real life so when you
enable workload identity on your cluster
your Google Cloud project gets an
identity namespace and within that
namespace you can identify your
kubernetes name your kubernetes service
accounts by a combination of their
kubernetes namespace and service account
name because the combination of a name
and its identity namespace is globally
unique and because the things that we're
naming are kubernetes service accounts
this means we can treat alice and
cluster a and allison cluster B as the
same person and for all the crypto nerds
in the room there is no Bob or Eve in
the story at all all right so consider
this simplified example we've got two
kubernetes clusters each have two pods
each have two namespaces you type two
your service accounts they're completely
independent from an authorization
standpoint the identities that exist in
these clusters are only relevant inside
these clusters but if we bind both of
these to the same identity namespace
then we can start thinking about logging
robot from an external context we can
start thinking about logging robot as
the same in both kubernetes cluster 1
and kubernetes cluster 2 if you toss in
a little Google magic we can then
associate logging robot with a Google
service account and use it to access
cloud services all right so I'm gonna
assume at this point the audience is
relatively split down the middle between
the how does that work group and the
show me how to use it group so next up
Mike is going to come up here and demo
how it all works in practice with a live
example assuming the demo is working and
then I'll come back up and we can do an
architectural lightning round for all
the architecture nerds I've oh wait one
more slide thank you I have this is my
example app it's actually a little bit
faded than it was but there are a couple
more boxes so in G K you
Swiss there's a box around the entire
thing and that represents my decayed
cluster and running in u.s. West there's
another box around it
fuzzy Lama and GCS server so I have this
app running in the fuzzy lama namespace
running is the GCS server service
account
I used the GCP project name generator to
get fuzzy llama and then I have another
GK cluster running in an Eastern zone
and it has a name space fuzzy llama and
my GCS server app running inside of it
and this is all running in my project
mech Denis Cadis so what these apps do
is they read object from GCS and serve
it to my customers so it's pretty
sophisticated app but we're gonna try to
set it up in this demo so you can switch
to the other screen now awesome so let's
get started first thing I'm gonna do is
I'm gonna deploy a cluster house the
size for everybody would you like it a
little bit bigger
alright thank you
so I'm deploying a app to our cluster to
us West 1d if you'll notice I'm passing
this flag identity namespace equals Mike
nice - Kate s so this is my project wide
identity namespace so I actually pre
created this cluster cuz it's a bit slow
and the next thing I'm gonna do is I'm
going to show you my app it's a pretty
concise app the yellow is the important
part so I'm using that Google's cloud
SDK just the default client libraries to
construct a token source if you are
familiar with how the token source works
in compute engine it just reads the
token from the metadata server I then
grab an OAuth client that uses that
token source and then I read one object
for GCS
so if we hop over to my kubernetes
config all I really have is a service
it's a load balanced service that is
serving on port 80 to expose my app to
the customer I have a service account
named GCS server running in the fuzzy
llama namespace and I have an annotation
on that service account that says I want
to run as the GCS server GCP I am
service account so this service account
has not been created yet and then at the
very bottom I have my deployment that
runs the app that we just looked at as
my GCS server kubernetes service again
so pretty straightforward let's see if
we can get it running
the first thing I'm gonna do is I'm
gonna create that GCS server servers
account and I'm gonna grab credentials
for my cluster and apply that
application config and then make sure
that that app is coming up so give it a
couple seconds looks like the GCS server
app is deployed and the next thing I'm
gonna do is I'm gonna give my kubernetes
service account permission to Breton as
the GCS server account the GCS server
I am service county so this is a bit
dense soil and packet we are adding
anion policy that grants GCS server in
the fuzzy llama namespace and Mike
Denise - Kade s identity namespace token
creator permission on the I am service
account that we want that app to run as
so this actually is the step that grants
my kubernetes service account permission
to use the I am service guy so that
looks good next thing I'm going to do
is I'm gonna pull that up in my West
cluster and I'm getting 403 forbidden
well that's probably because we haven't
given my application permission to read
that object so next thing I'm gonna do
is I'm gonna use gsutil change Akal to
grant that GCP service count permission
to read that image or that object and we
get kind of what we expect I also notice
this will be important when we set up
the second half of the demo that the
cluster and name is exposed as a red
header so let's go set up the second
half of the demo so I'm gonna do the
exact same thing the cluster is called
East but it's employed in US central I
actually also pre created this cluster
so next thing I'm going to do is I'm
gonna grab credentials for it and then
I'm gonna apply the same application
config and make sure it's running
looks looks pretty good and then what
I'm gonna do is I'm gonna pull East and
West at the same time so as you can see
this one hit West that one hit East so
both my applications are able to read
GCS at that GCS object the reason we
didn't have to add any Eccles to set up
the the eastern cluster is because both
clusters are in the same identity
namespace so google authenticates them
at its the same service account so the
last thing that we will do in this demo
is i'm gonna revoke echo and just to
bring that principle home it this Akal
revoke will apply to both clusters
simultaneously so West just failed and
east just failed so wesson East are
running the same service that my GCS
server application spans both those
clusters and that's the demo thank you
okay I promised you an architectural
lightening round for those of you who
kept your hands up in the beginning this
this fits for you there are five
fundamental new components there exist
as a part of this new feature first we
have an OID C provider that runs on
Google's infrastructure it provides
cluster specific metadata and it signs
jots there is a new gke metadata server
it runs as a daemon set meaning one
instance on every node it emulates the
existing VMs metadata server but it
exposes pod specific data this is going
to provide backwards compatibility with
old client libraries right and it also
offers like built-in metadata
concealment and I figure you are
familiar with that feature that's in
beta today on gke it isolates some
secrets that exist in the GCE metadata
server from being exposed to your
workloads this is built into this new
metadata server as well we also have a
new annotation that you saw earlier on
the surface account lets you indicate
which GCP service account you want to
act as that's not actually a security
boundary but we do need it to provide
the hint and then of course we have
Google I am it issues access tokens
validates bindings the new thing is it
also validates oh I DC signatures now
and then Google Cloud out large it
accepts access tokens and it does pretty
much anything we're gonna walk through
the flow now there's two steps that are
left out and that's an authorized user
binding the cluster to the namespace you
saw Mike do that earlier and the second
is the workload needs to try and do
something to try and access a Google
cloud service using a client library
once that happens the GAE metadata
server is going to request an OID C
signed a jot from the control plane and
then I'm sorry I shouldn't oh that that
connection is authenticated using mutual
TLS and it uses the nodes identity as
the client cert then the GAE metadata
server is going to use that o ADC sync
to request an access token for the
identity namespace slash kubernetes
service account from I am I am gonna
validate that the appropriate bindings
exist and then it's going to validate
that it was signed by the clusters
correct Oh IDC provider it's gonna been
gonna return an access token and this
access token remember is for the
identity namespace slash kubernetes
service account then the metadata server
is going to send that access token it
just got back to I am and I am gonna
exchange that for a short-lived GCP
service account token after validating
the appropriate bindings of course then
jika jika a metadata server returns that
token up to the workload and the
workload can obviously use that to make
calls to any GCP service there's a lot
of token exchanges and validations going
on but in practice what this means is
once you've done the configuration and
set up your work your identity namespace
your identity in Google cloud is
determined by the kubernetes service
account that your workload is running as
and everything else
[Music]